Wow.
Well,
well,
go to your mom's house,
Christina Vincent Brown dog.
You've been warned.
Brown,
Brown.
Hey.
Oh my God.
You guys are so disgusting.
Brown,
barge
board,
the Orlando Airport.
Hey Buddy.
Every Saul is
the Orlando airport.
All we all,
we always falling.
They pay.
They want to take it down.
Take it down
in between the,
if the plot
my buddy,
take it up,
take it down.
They went right buddy,
buddy,
buddy.
Oh my God.
You guys are so disgusting.
Brown,
Brown.
Hey Buddy.
How are you doing?
We do 800 to a thousand times a year,
right?
Right,
right.
All right.
Uh,
that was gaping dad.
I'm really impressed with his work late.
He's really,
really sent in some hits and um,
I've got a bunch of other songs.
Maybe we can go through some of them.
I forgot that.
Funny.
Clever.
Hey,
what you doing homie?
Yeah,
taking the shit.
They a shit homie.
Um,
and every time I hear Jane do that,
Oh my God,
you guys are just so disgusting.
I know.
It makes me smile every time.
Yeah,
it's so her,
oh my God.
You guys are just so disgusting.
You really,
really,
that's really authentic.
Yeah.
She really hates it.
What an appropriate song for today's episode two is.
We're both,
uh,
we're in it,
but no,
no,
no.
Not both of us.
I'm,
no,
I've just had normal bowel movements today.
You're the one that we need to really go back and do an autopsy and figuring out
what's going on here.
It's not good.
Well,
let's,
let's go through it.
Um,
okay.
Let's,
um,
uh,
where a lot of my God,
you guys are so disgusting.
Yeah.
That's genuine contempt.
Yeah,
she's done that.
You can't fake that.
Oh my God.
Seriously.
There's a lot going on.
Well,
why don't we do our proper show open?
Yeah.
That we can get into all of it.
She's doing homie.
What you doing?
What you doing,
homie?
[inaudible] going to show me.
Let's do this.
There we go.
That'll be helping me with this
reading.
They're nice and sheer.
Um,
you're ready.
Oh,
let's see here.
it's ready to be read.
Here we go.
Oh,
it'd be a,
just turn up the,
Oh,
there we go.
Okay.
Now we can get a reading out of this.
Uh
Huh.
Was Randy don't bring anyone loving to this.
Well go to your mom's house.
She told
Christina
so much to cover today.
Nasty,
nasty as hell.
So this is the worst one I would say.
Of all the things we've had on this show,
the Vegan Vagina guy.
Um,
I mean,
you know,
dudes barfing like that for some reason.
Just really skeeves me out.
That's the worst of all.
Feels.
It doesn't feel good to me to watch that part.
Why not as nasty as hell.
She called them that parent nasty.
Drowsy.
Hmm.
She really liked that one.
That's the one you chose for the opener,
Huh?
Yeah.
I all the clips submitted to us of all the potential dad boner things or,
Yup.
Hey Mommy.
Thanks gene.
That that's what you chose.
That's the one that I thought would upset you the most.
Yeah.
Mission accomplished.
Nasty as hell.
It's so nasty.
She reading vaginal discharge or discharge,
she can read.
She can tell the future by her panties.
Oh,
her panties?
Yes.
That's her discharge.
That's hers.
And she,
damn,
that is nasty as hell.
Yeah.
It's nasty.
He is the cheese.
Yeah.
Girl.
I guy be so nasty.
Gross Dude.
It's really gross.
Why did you have to bring that into my life?
Pup play was nasty as hell.
Tell me all these nasty he healed.
This is just,
this might be that the the panicle.
Um,
so just to give you a little set up here,
the lady,
well why don't I let her say first five minutes of the show has been horrendous.
It's,
it's all been shit.
Shit talk and now panty Talenti reading though.
Yeah.
She can read a psychic.
That woman if you,
you know,
it was hard to tell.
She can,
she can hold up her own panties and,
and like a psychic tell what's going to happen by what she's discharging I to
them.
Oh,
okay.
Hi.
It's amber from listener near face.com and use panty selling if vice.com and I'm
going to do something that I usually don't,
I usually just sort of a,
have it be private time before things are sent off to their new living home.
That beyond,
she's high as he calls it reading.
Oh,
shades are serious too,
but she's stoned as hell.
You didn't tell her she got cotton mouth pretty bad.
Yeah,
she's,
she's whacked and she's got,
um,
the really big thick,
you know the sunglasses.
They're like,
they're like fucking,
what do they call like blue blockers?
Basics.
There's no blue blockers.
Let you see everything crisper and clearer.
Right,
right.
But there's no water.
There's no light penetrating.
Those are black,
black Jackie Onassis.
Um,
yeah.
If I can say,
dude.
Anyway,
go ahead.
I forget.
I'll remember
have this long run.
It's a sheer aqua marine c k thumb and yeah,
it's a part of that resurrected collection that I mentioned a few weeks back
that was sent back to me for reimburse vacation.
That is nasty as house.
I understand.
I got it.
And like the 90s and then they're like,
could you re nasty these isn't it nuts to make their living doing this?
I think it's the most ingenious thing I've ever seen.
Aquamarine.
I mean if you're a woman with little education or means to create a living for
yourself,
that's probably the best way to do it.
Well,
you gotta be so gender specific.
Why can't a guy do it?
I'm sure there are dudes that are like,
I love it guys.
Filthy coarser but stained of course.
That's what I'm saying.
They'll cut us out.
I'm not kicking you out of the picture.
I'm just saying that vaginal discharge is,
well yeah,
but I'm saying of course we were talking about vaginal,
but I'm saying you can't,
you can't compete with vaginal juices is what I'm saying.
All that stuff.
Does it come out throughout the day though?
Does it change with your cycles?
Probably not like that,
but I mean you can get,
you know,
you can get a little pre come
on those he was painting.
That's an interesting point too.
And you can also get a little yellow because my step father,
I remember my mother would wash his boxers and she would point out that there
was yellow and brown.
Oh yeah.
Brown stains.
So you can yellow yellow for sure.
You can get you yellow on on yours.
I normally wear,
I'm sure I normally have on black or gray boxers.
Right?
So we don't know.
I'm going to switch you to white boxers only.
I'm going to start evaluating what
I kind of want you.
Let's send it to amber.
She can amplification it.
There we go.
That'll be helping me with this little reading.
They're nice and sheer,
um,
melded.
Let's see here.
Oh Bitch,
let me go.
It'd be a,
just turn up the,
okay,
now we can get a reading out of this.
God Damn.
Well,
first of all,
I mean,
look,
I'm not a doctor,
but if you're,
what's coming out of you,
it add a [inaudible] coming out of your front is brownish intent.
You got an infection that's not normal,
that coloring now.
Well,
I mean,
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah,
it shouldn't,
it shouldn't be Brown.
I mean unless it's period stuff,
but
she got burned burnt by gonorrhea.
I mean if it's not a period thing,
I'd be very concerned.
But I don't know,
maybe amber is menstruating,
I don't know.
And we're going to find out.
So there's a little bit of an overlapping,
right?
There are two different colors,
kind of a melding.
And what that suggests is that I'm going to get a massage today and then I'm
going to be giving somebody else in the Scottish.
So like a little bit of an exchange going on
the two over overlapping colors.
Tell her that there was a massage and her future.
That's what she is doing.
Well that's really not fair because she knows what she's going to be doing today
is that you can't do a psychic reading on yourself.
And then I'm touching this,
right?
I'm going to have a doctor's appointment at four.
I mean,
you know what you're doing today.
So if she could read my panties and be accurate,
then I'd really be surprised if she goes any further
and then,
um,
up or it's actually down cause I have these upside down.
Um,
feeding onto the back portion of the phone right there.
God,
this is amazing.
It's a color which indicates that I will be fed.
Well today.
You guys,
are we just gonna Cook for me
now is that planned or does she really reading the future?
Well that's what's problematic about this clip Tom,
is I feel like we don't know if this is really accurate and we don't know if
this is truly a psychic thing.
I wonder if she's going to watch that hand after this.
It's her own mine.
You wash your hands after you touch your own.
Of course you never do.
You never wash your hands.
I've seldom seen you and what you call hand washing is piss poor.
Oh,
I've seen you,
you,
you and cold water.
First of all,
everybody knows you have to use hot water height as possible and steaming.
You do use coal.
Why you flip it on and then you've,
this is the stream.
You just flick your,
the tips of your fingers under it like this and then you,
you do like half a pump us up and then you kind of switch a it in your finger
tips.
It's like a pea wash,
right?
It's a brown wash is different.
Walk me through it.
Go ahead Brown.
I go hot water.
Two hands.
I Dunno man.
At least five seconds to scrub the backs of your hands as well for that go
across surgery.
I'm just going to wash my hands.
You want to get another cold?
No,
I want to get flu.
wash the back of your fucking hands.
All right.
Maybe I will.
Well,
let's see here.
Oh,
back up to the top right there.
Damn Dude,
I thought we were done.
Interesting little amber vacation going almost onto the sheer part of pants.
You right there and what that suggests is that I am going to take the most
divine bath in the most divine outdoor
lab.
What else?
Chick's got a great life.
I have to say.
It is a pretty good,
she's got a massage lined up.
She's got to,
someone's going to cook dinner for her and she's going to be in the bathtub.
So you think she's mentally ill?
No,
I think she's mentally stoned.
Hi.
And she that,
that would be funny.
And then,
yeah,
you know when you get stone you think something's going to be funny and then you
try it later and you're like,
oh,
it's not funny.
It was high thought.
Could have been a pot thought and then no,
but a for effort,
you know,
you got to put it out there.
You got to try.
Yeah.
Well amber furcation and verification money,
I was like Braxton word.
There's a lot going on yesterday.
Some of you might know was my smurf day.
And
don't make yourself equal with the g.
Why?
Because G is g and t is t [inaudible] birthday to take g have a birthday to case
such a fucking shit deck.
So we had a nice little party at the house we barbecued.
We had cousin Bri,
Bri over and yeah.
You know,
cousin Yanette and my dad and babies and doggies.
And it was fun.
I got it.
I listened to you yawn as you talk about how French finally hands tired.
I'm always tired.
It was a,
it was a fun time.
The weekend I had a blast.
I was in San Jose meet rattle and Portland,
Oregon three and I approve of one of those cities.
Why,
why in California?
Oh right.
It's still not la,
but at least it's in the right state.
Of course,
the super elitist that you are,
but I do enjoy Seattle and Portland.
[inaudible] those are fantastic cities.
I had a great time.
The shows were a lot of fun.
And actually,
um,
for two of the cities meet rattle in Portland.
My cousin Bree Bree joined me.
It's adorable.
Yeah.
So for those of you that don't know,
Bree,
Bree and I,
um,
you know,
we grew up together.
We were next door neighbors for the first nine years of our lives and now we
both live in La.
We both have babies around the same age too,
around the same age,
which is cool.
So it was fun just to hang out and uh,
you know,
we had meals and just,
he just hung out backstage.
And you know,
enjoyed the life,
the showbiz life showbiz baby.
Yeah.
So he came home and then so,
so we had our barbecue and now today I made spaghetti squash.
Like I got it from whole farts.
Yeah.
And I put some sausage in there.
I mean my sinuses are all fucked up.
This morning I've been blowing boogers that are like neon yellow.
I was terrified by the way.
Monday we did this show Monday last week and we were both really sick and I was
super legit scared that I was going to have the upcoming weekend because of how
I felt.
I was like thinking,
I mean there's no way I can do this.
There's a life wrecker that called.
I go out,
there's no way I can do six shows in three cities like this.
No.
And I got some meds and thank God I got through.
It was did you take antibiotics?
I did.
Oh well that's why you're not,
because it's date 11 and I'm still sick.
I'm still congested.
My snot has changed color.
It's a bright yellow.
Yeah,
you don't,
you're not as,
you know,
I'm fucked.
I got to go to the doctor and get those antibiotics,
man,
I think this is,
this is evil.
What's inside of me now our kids find though.
Yeah,
he's better.
So even though you have aids,
no,
I'm fine.
You,
yeah,
I got to go get it.
I'm going to go.
Uh,
so then I made spaghetti squash and I don't feel like eating anything.
This has been like a,
a week long for me where like farts and,
um,
I have just been bad
and sour while you've been in three different cities in the last weekend.
So I'll always take into account different bacteria of the different cities.
Yeah.
And when I picked up these meds from the pharmacy,
um,
the lady was like,
have you taken this before?
And I go,
yeah.
And then when did you take it was an antibiotic,
just like penicillin,
not penicillin.
Like a variant of it.
Yeah.
I'm oxys Phil.
I have to look up what it was.
But she's goes,
you taken this before.
And I go,
yeah.
And then I paid and as I walk away,
she goes,
you could get diarrhea.
And I go,
thank you.
And I didn't get diarrhea from it,
but the next day I started to have like just like rotten
smelly.
Yeah.
And nothing feels good to eat when you're sitting.
I know.
I haven't eaten well in the last 10 days.
I don't want to eat anything except melted cheese and crackers.
Couldn't find the thing.
I was looking for it and it's like I just,
it was just terrible,
you know,
I just couldn't really figure it out.
And then,
um,
when we got to Portland I was going to go to that,
uh,
fuck it.
What's it called?
Some,
I think it has like a Vietnamese name.
It's across the street kind of from the salt shake place.
Uh,
it really popular.
Yeah.
Oh I've been there.
I've been there.
And you,
you get like your thing arise,
you meet and your veggies.
Is that the place?
I don't know.
Yeah,
dude,
I threw my name.
It's like a hole in the wall.
Cause Sorta.
Anyway,
maybe I'm thinking so,
um,
anyways,
you put her name in and then they're like play 45 minutes.
And I was like,
no way.
My waiting.
Let's get your entire fucking life together.
Yeah.
So we walked down the street and there's like food truck,
uh,
like park basically love that area.
And this is beautiful day outside and the university,
right?
Don't know Portland.
Yeah.
I'm not sure because,
but there's probably like 12 trucks right in a circle and then like,
uh,
a central area you can hang out afterwards.
We're walking through it,
trying to figure out what we're going to eat and then bribe right points out to
me that there's a burger place and I said,
you can put your Burger on a field of Greens.
So I'm like,
perfect.
Right.
I get some meat,
get some fat and get some veggies with it.
Like,
which is how I like to eat.
Right.
So I go,
I get it.
It was okay if I'm going to be honest.
It was just okay.
No,
it
was this one of those places where everybody's like,
you gotta eat there.
No,
I wouldn't know because I'm just saying that like we were,
we were going to go to the really popular place and it was so packed.
We walked down the street to this food truck,
little park.
And then anyways,
if the place is the whole fucking park is packed,
people are,
are all over the place there.
But I eat that thing and within 30 minutes I'm like,
Oh man,
that didn't settle.
Well,
part of that I think is I didn't have bread so I don't have anything absorbing
any of the,
yeah.
Like fuck the Diet just to get whatever you can.
Yeah.
That is sort of the best philosophy for that.
Anyways,
I eat it.
I have like really rotten farts and dumps out the rotten parts begin,
I would say.
I mean,
they all kind of were,
we're kicking,
you know,
throughout the week.
But that Burger was on Saturday and that's the first time that's like,
Oh,
a pad.
And that's as far as,
I mean,
I just shot you who out of my ass.
You know,
this problem started back in on Saturday.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So we're talking.
Yeah.
Okay.
So your guts have been,
yeah,
they were just wrecked.
So then,
sure.
Um,
after that we see where the hotel,
I'm trying to remember where we ate next.
Um,
and then yeah,
then we went to the show.
I don't,
I'm not remembering if eating.
So I took one of my little pouches,
little like Keto food pouch.
It's like 200 calorie thing.
I ate just to have something to me a little bit after that.
And then I just had,
it was drinking tea all week.
You know what's great about tea by the way?
Every time I get sick I drink 40 cups of tea and I enjoy it.
And as soon as I get better,
I abandoned t well t's good because it's comforting when you're,
you have a cold.
I know what I'm saying.
I like it so much.
It's like I always try and get done.
I'm healthy.
I don't like a hot beverage necessarily,
like a tea coffee though.
I like how coffee makes me feel.
I don't like coffee with the coffee.
Okay.
It's like beer.
I drink it to get fucked up.
My drinking it for the tape.
Um,
so,
but we'll wait a minute and then,
yeah.
And then,
okay,
so I got you a juice from whole foods.
Let's go back to yesterday.
Had Brussels sprouts.
I made you call.
It wobbles your favorite.
I also had a lot yesterday.
My birthday,
I had some,
some meat,
some collywobbles,
um,
some chicken.
And then from whole fire corn,
little corn salad,
cupcake,
cupcake cake with a piece of that.
That was a lot of sugar.
A lot of sugar.
I'm not used to consuming,
Yana allow me to present to the court my possible findings here.
Okay.
I went to whole foods this morning and I brought you back the juice.
Yes.
So let's go to this morning.
This morning I had a spinach and egg.
No,
no.
I'm going through all of it.
Right,
right.
I'm having a spinach and egg scramble,
which is normal for me.
I have it all the time and it does nothing to me.
That is all I've had until you bring me the juice from whole farts.
I drink that.
I don't drink all of it.
I drink about,
let's say close to half of it.
And then you made a,
what does that a spaghetti squash.
Squash Spaghetti and I got some whole farts.
Getedge Zucchini and squash and noodle form and noodle form some whole fart
sausage dude.
As soon as I took the last bite of that,
my insides went
and then I ran to the bathroom.
Shit,
everything out.
Good for you.
And then 10 minutes later my stomach's going
just rumbling,
man.
Terrible.
I'm jealous because I'm backed up a little bit.
I even went to Korean food on Saturday hoping to loosen things up for me,
but to no avail.
I took one shit after that.
Spaghetti squash,
but it was a normal one.
So I,
you know what?
I think it is for you.
I think it's the juice from wholefoods a,
but here's my argument against that.
I have that juice sometimes and I'm okay,
but you're not listening.
So it's the juice and your vegetable intake,
which I know you historically,
you can't really handle vegetables.
Your body like freaks out.
I think it might be the spaghetti squash in conjunction with the collywobbles
from last night.
And they choose the Jews,
the Jews,
the Jews did it.
Shoes.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Different parts of your underwear.
It could be the sugar,
but I don't know,
but that's where I'm at.
So right now,
what do I do moving forward for the rest of the day?
You have to eat carb.
You know when your,
when your diary Ang you have to have like a pasta or something or crackers.
He got to fuck the Diet.
Um,
you know,
I had an epiphany though by the way,
when I had Korean food on Saturday and I ordered their spicy Soondubu,
it's like a tofu soup and I get it read like I like it very spicy now.
Are you farting when you do
now?
I had this epiphany because I was eating it and I was thinking to myself,
Gosh,
in my early twenties I used to,
that's when I started eating this stuff.
I used to get diarrhea every time that I would eat this soup.
Like an hour later I'd be bent over on the toilet and pain,
but now I can eat it.
And it doesn't even like a failure tolerance.
Exactly.
It took a decade of eating Soondubu and now I can eat it in the sh and Kimchi.
I can eat a whole trough of it and like it doesn't phase me.
I went to Korea and I was the only one not to get diarrhea because I was,
I show is going to the malls and eating that hot spicy soup and all the other
white girls.
Hey,
it took a decade though cause that's how long I would shit after I would eat
Korean and then when they stop diarrhea.
When you did,
when you started doing standup too?
I had diarrhea for the first seven years of standoffs.
Not Crazy.
Yeah,
violent.
Just w w when I knew I had to set that night,
I would wake up and start shedding and I would shit all day.
And then,
then why did the Groundlings before that and then the Groundlings,
that was like an all day shit and then I would shit before the Groundlings.
And then during the class break you remember you'd had a break?
I was shit during the break.
I mean I was a nervous wreck for seven years.
Easily.
Now.
How did,
did you get nerves like that for performing or
not diarrhea,
but I remember,
I remember the very first time I ever did stand up,
I woke up,
I had booked a like,
you know,
it's a Saturday and a month kind of thing.
And I was like,
all right,
the week of I'm thinking about it,
you know,
it was getting real and I remember I wrote out every single word.
Yeah.
And I remember the night before,
you know,
really thinking about it.
Right.
Reading and writing it over and,
and,
and being like,
oh my God,
you know,
I have this tomorrow and the next morning,
this is like when I'm obviously single.
I have nothing to do on a Saturday night.
I snap out of bed at five 30 in the morning.
Like I,
I wake up in a panic.
I'm like,
I'm doing stand,
hold,
sweat,
like that nervous.
And I remember having,
you know,
for me it was like I can't eat,
oh yeah,
that sale.
I couldn't eat.
I would eat like protein bars,
but I would still,
shit,
I couldn't eat the night of the show.
I might've eaten like a granola bar.
Really?
Yeah.
Um,
I did some
and that's what I smoked cigarettes.
So I would chain smoke all day two out of nerves.
Yeah.
That was,
uh,
when I think about it,
the re that havoc I wreaked on my immune system,
on my,
my adrenals are just fucking shot from the right.
The first 10 years of stand up easily.
There was a shot.
I remember the first time that I actually did it too.
I've said it before,
but I got a,
uh,
I got,
I got boobs,
you know,
and
not the first time you did it the first time.
Yeah.
You got booed.
Booze.
I was drinking.
I was who's,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's dangerous.
Oh my God.
I was terrified,
man.
Well,
of course.
Yeah.
I had the good fortune.
I,
I took an actual standup comedy class,
believe when I did that a million years ago.
This is,
I think I was in the Groundlings and I just want to know like,
oh,
what stand up about?
And the teacher said one great thing.
He goes,
don't get into the habit of drinking or doing drugs before you perform in the
beginning because then it's a really hard thing to break later.
And I thought,
oh that's,
that's good advice.
I'm going to try that out.
Cause that you really can't once you get hooked on doing it that way.
Yeah.
I that uh,
Joe Rogan
told me,
cause I used to smoke cigarettes around shows.
Oh yeah.
It wasn't a big smoker,
but I started to get into the ritual of doing it like smoking before and after.
He was like,
well what if you start like you're in demand more than you and you need to do
shows all the time.
Like you're working more than you are now.
That's just going to make you smoke even more.
Like what,
you know what I mean?
Like you're,
you're making it so that every time you do a set,
you're smoking.
But what if you even start doing more sets that your health is going to yeah.
Yeah.
So I just started associated to,
and I was like,
Oh yeah,
yeah.
That's the danger.
You,
you make those,
those associations.
I was 2010 I think.
Yeah,
that was the last time I smoked.
Yeah.
Good.
Good gene.
Yeah,
smoking is bad.
I did something.
I don't know if you're going to be very happy with,
Oh God.
I hope you don't get upset,
but I hope you can find the humor in it.
Uh,
the last time we made love.
Yeah.
I hit an audio room
quarter in the room.
Oh,
you did?
Just audio.
Yeah,
that's fine.
So,
you know,
we're so close to our audience.
I figured,
you know,
let's share with them what I love making session two.
Married,
loving people.
Yeah.
Okay.
So let me,
um,
as long as it's not the visual,
I don't want people to see how gross we aren't,
they,
they won't see us,
but here they're going to hear us and I hope that,
okay.
I hope I'm not too embarrassed.
Yeah.
I hope you're okay with it.
Let's see here.
Let's see if this,
okay.
Put music to it so that kind of give it a little extra flavor.
You know how you're so talented.
Yeah.
Like our ancestors worship each other floor.
I mean there.
You know,
it's funny when I get into a such a frenzied state with you.
I don't know what I'm saying.
Worship me like our ancestors worshiped each other before.
Yeah.
You're trying to say something more profound almost.
Well,
I was talking about the Egyptians.
I was reading about Tooton common.
Yeah,
and it was just,
it's all stream of consciousness.
I was meditating earlier.
Yeah.
I got smoked a little weed before we did it.
Interesting
fucking job.
Right?
That was a fun one.
Okay.
Remember that time?
Yeah.
Did your daughters better ball Warsh
this was a curious to me.
You said your daughter's,
can I be a better ball?
Worship
me.
Great.
I'm lost.
You didn't remember.
You don't remember talking about that that high.
We had a kid and we have a daughter or she'd be a ball worshiper.
You don't remember that discussion we had before we made last?
Yeah.
We were like,
who's going to be a better ball?
Where Zuber our son or our daughter.
It was like we had that debate and then,
oh,
now I remember.
Yeah.
Okay.
Thank you.
No
[inaudible] [inaudible]
that was quite a night.
That was,
You're right.
Yup.
That was the night.
I'm just embarrassed that you recorded that.
I mean,
I,
you don't seem that embarrassed,
which I'm proud of you.
You're owning who you are.
Well,
you know,
we're all at different strokes.
Yup.
Same folks.
Same folks,
same strokes.
Talk to me like you're fucking white,
your fucking wife,
right?
Yeah.
It's a different fantasy we have.
So you were like pretending like you're not my wife.
Right.
That's what we do.
This is a,
this is crystal.
You're banging.
No,
you don't really,
you're not really saying much here.
Well,
I'm so focused on how,
on your performance.
That's what I was like,
wow.
Like,
you know,
it was kind of lost in it.
Yeah.
I get,
I get carried away.
You always,
yeah.
All it takes this one glass of Chardonnay and I really
interesting
[inaudible]
I piped up there.
Yeah,
you were really aggressive there.
Yeah.
But you were coaching me into it.
You say like you wanted it.
Yeah,
I did.
Yeah.
I was trying to be like,
hey,
you run this show and you said like say something.
Say something stupid.
Yeah.
So you did I let you hear it.
Wow.
Sounds like you wanted to hear it.
[inaudible] I tell you I got to start selecting your clips from now.
We got to,
so far you've been really just hitting the high notes on this show.
I mean Albany with the Panty lady and then the second clip as this.
I mean
he really need my help with the show a little more.
I should've stepped in this week.
I'll be honest.
I wasn't feeling well.
I mean where do we go from here?
I'm talking about you can't open on this.
I was about to close on this.
I was too excited to play it.
I've,
I've found this one myself.
This wasn't an art or is it just in your normal repertoire?
This was just your weekend Brian.
So proud of you.
Oh Man.
I think I got it.
I mean are we,
is there a lot more?
There's about another minute and a half.
Oh my God.
What's going to happen?
I feel like I know where it's at.
Of course you were there.
Fucking
musics were really good.
I was thinking about the music.
Yeah,
it doesn't fit does it?
Here's what I'm imagining though now if it doesn't fit,
but there's a couple of guys that play right.
And one of them is really like,
he really has a passion for music and for him it's like
he's just happy that he has another guy to play with.
Like he's like the keyboard,
the other guy does the guitar or whatever and the guitar guy sold it to these
boring people and the other guy doesn't know yet.
He goes,
hey man,
I actually got someone a license,
our music to feature film.
What did it fucking awesome.
Like I told you all this time it's going to pay off.
Like we've been getting together.
We're getting serious about our music.
Yeah.
And now you're telling me someone wants it in a movie.
Yeah,
man,
somebody wants it in their movie and uh,
I just got a little clip of it.
You can hear what we did in a movie now.
Oh,
I want to come on.
She seems like a lot.
What does it sound?
Is it CSI?
What's that?
Music don't,
don't,
what is that shit?
No,
that is,
uh,
don't,
that's law and order.
Yeah.
It sounds like the law and order theme a little bit in order.
Well you had that on deck.
Yeah.
That's the theme to dig detectives.
Oh,
right,
right.
Yeah.
That was kind of a failed game for us only because it was hard to verify dicks.
Dicks.
Like we,
you can only really theorize on what somebody's Dick looks like.
And we've,
we just didn't have a lot of verifications.
Yeah.
But it was fun to guess.
Maybe we'll,
uh,
we'll play again in May when I have guests in May.
If we can find,
if we could find a guest who would be willing to show us a picture of his dick.
To do though is just,
is come up.
Even if they don't verify,
they take a stance on what it looks like.
It's the game.
So make a drawing.
Yeah.
Something like that with crayons or write down the features that we go,
it hangs on the left,
right.
It smells weird.
Right?
Screen and then big balls.
Little balls.
High balls.
Yeah.
Fat sloppers.
Yeah,
Harry.
There you go.
Yeah.
You don't have to play that clip anymore.
I'm good.
What part of it do you not like anymore?
It's just,
it's a long,
I mean,
we did it for so long that night and I didn't realize,
I thought you would like it more.
I really did.
Hearing myself.
Yeah,
the playback.
I'm so embarrassed.
I thought you would really like it more.
No,
I didn't think you were.
Oh,
where's your water?
Tom?
Deal with your bullshit every day.
Oh,
okay.
I got it.
I mean,
I just,
I don't know why.
Why?
Why don't you have to have this?
All right.
Don't,
don't you know your z via was a real hit yesterday.
The Barbie people loved it.
Especially your father.
I know.
He really enjoyed my cvs.
Now my dad likes shitty sodas though.
He's a fool right now.
You've never said that sentence in your life.
Now you're like,
he likes shitty sodas.
Well,
you know what his favorite one is?
No.
Fresca all right,
sounds cool.
Frasca is gross and no,
of course he's going to like your gross soda here.
This will hopefully cleanse your palette choices.
So far.
This is something a little innocent,
Fun Little Dad Boehner Club.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh,
hold on.
There we go.
Boom,
boom.
Late 18 hundreds community bottle dump is always a fun dig yesterday's trash.
Today's treasure.
First of all,
the fact that he did a real walk up,
you know,
standing on the intro for this,
like a television guy would write and he had the,
the the bottle out of frame.
This guy is really committed to his dad.
Boner.
Passionate.
Yes.
Yup,
Yup.
Can't wear shredded close on camera.
It doesn't look,
this is what these guys do.
They dig an old,
an old dump sites for things like bottles,
you know?
All right.
We're just starting to open it up.
We've got a
wood and John Chavon,
Gargoyle Ridge.
You can see the stratification and got a layer of rust here and then getting
into the ash layer.
These guys,
I mean,
how fucking bored do you have to be to think this is interesting.
I know,
and they're,
they're,
they're dig like they're digging in the woods where people dump the bottles 200
years old.
It's like I'm a landfill,
right?
Yeah.
And they're like,
look at all the trash is he read lady where the ash had other trash.
Oh,
look at the time.
That's total the caucus stolen at all.
That's crazy.
Look at that.
Yeah,
it is.
Yeah.
I'm in Chicago.
Oil's got some motion cod liver oil that sweet with lime and soda.
How?
I love the toad.
Yeah,
me too.
Wow.
Getting nerd.
A bunch of dorks.
Abby Birthday.
How old are you now?
Yeah,
we got a blue.
Oh,
we got a cold bar.
Delf deangelis providence.
Oh,
that's cool.
I know Joe.
Joe.
We were in someone else's bag.
Dude.
That's a real to just,
just his pants over an old bottle.
Yeah.
You found a bottle.
He fucking trash.
This guy is excited about trash.
No further record.
This was for you playing this over.
Okay.
Thanks Ben.
Yeah.
Don't.
All right,
let's go to John's here.
See what shot big medicine.
It does have a sunken,
Oh yeah,
panel.
Oh,
that's it's that whole mass.
Barilla.
Barilla,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
The whole,
the whole,
have you ever dug one John Smith's crosswords?
Hopefully this one.
He got a cracked one earlier.
Let's hope this is a whole one.
Looks good.
Get that fucking nerd.
Wow.
I really stoked about these bottles,
Huh?
Yeah.
Well glass bottle.
Okay.
Yeah.
Ah,
it's for,
for a bottle glass bottle.
Was the glass bottle that much better back in the 18 hundreds?
It's just fucking door cause they have nothing to do.
Yeah,
they live in some awful place.
You know,
like you say,
that's as a terrible place.
Wherever that is.
It's definitely not la.
It's not interested.
Not Interested.
No,
not uh,
no.
I mean I guess it's nice to have hobbies and stuff.
I know I'm sort of jealous of that.
By the way.
Can we bring this up
hobby wise?
I have for many years expressed my interest in aviation
and I've taken a flying lesson.
I don't think my eyes can roll,
crawl back in my head.
Farmer.
Now
I've told you I want to continue my pursuit of a pilot's license.
And your proposal is that we come up with a formula where a certain amount of
blow jobs will equal yes.
Not getting a pilot's license.
Exactly.
Now I asked you,
how many blow jobs would it take for you to lose interest in helicopter
piloting?
Yeah,
so let's do the math.
Let's go.
I mean,
obviously I'm,
uh,
I'm congested now,
so,
you know what I mean?
Can you have some mercy?
Yeah.
Well,
here's the,
okay.
To receive a private pilot license,
the FAA requires student pilots have a minimum of 40 hours of flight time.
Um,
let's see.
So I think we should do something like some tradeoff for
how many blow jobs can you do in an hour?
Probably like five
an hour.
Oh,
come on.
Let's be real.
You're 38.
You're not 28 or eight.
No,
no.
I'm saying how many could you do to other people like you and
no,
I'm saying 40 hours are required.
So if you were going to do 40 hours of blowjobs,
you could probably give out,
you know,
200 blowjobs.
I think you should be about 200 blow jobs.
But they need to be,
you know,
obviously to completion,
obviously facials,
obviously.
Yeah.
Why?
Obviously facial,
because you're crushing a dream with these blessings guy to like,
you know,
fulfill.
Yeah.
But I'm not crushing the dream.
I'm,
I'm fulfilling dreams too.
Don't forget that.
Yeah.
How a blowjob you think you could give to like a whole group of people.
You should go off at that one.
You give me the number and let's negotiate because I don't like this hobby.
I don't want you flying.
I have a relative that was killed in a,
he was a pilot for many,
many 30 years and was killed flying.
So I'm very biased against,
and don't fucking send me emails telling me how safe it is.
I had a relative die,
so I don't fucking care.
I don't care.
And he flew for a living.
Here's what I'm saying,
blow jobs
that you give.
I mean,
I think it'd be different if I was like,
didn't you know it wasn't close to you?
Like if I was just like your friend and you're like,
I don't want you to fly,
then you're like,
what if I give you blowjobs?
It's like that's pretty much right,
but as your husband blowjobs are part of the relationship as it is,
I'm offering bonus material,
don't you get it?
But then like how,
which blowjobs are like life blow jobs in which our pilot blowjobs
I'm saying what the number is going to have to be much higher because there'd be
blow jobs anyways.
Bam.
Because you're,
look,
you're,
you're getting greedy.
I can ingredient being honest.
Do you understand what I'm actually trying to say?
You're saying what's the surplus amount versus the regular?
There you go.
That's a legit question.
Well,
you need to think about it and then we have to come up with some numbers and
we'll negotiate.
And also in what timeframe will they be in a lifetime lifetime.
Come on.
We're married for life.
So these are going to be blowjobs from getting in 20 years for the pilot's
license.
Okay,
fine.
Three years.
That's a better answer.
Okay.
I think,
um,
I have a really good proposal for you.
No negotiating.
How was that an assignment and a proposal then?
You're a dictator.
Just do one a week.
Every week for three years.
What about sickness kid thing?
You get a pass on sickness when?
A week for how long?
For years.
How long?
Three years.
And you'll never talk about this piloting license again.
I think that's,
um,
know I in writing.
I want our attorney to draft up a legally binding document that for the rest of
our marriage,
I never fucking hear about pilot license or flying or race car driving.
Wait,
wait,
wait a minute.
I can get you killed is not,
I was not your honor.
That's not part of the negotiation.
We're talking about flying only cars are now part of the equation races.
I'm,
but you don't want to race car drive.
I'm just saying like why?
Why you have to have a hobby that can potentially kill you and take you away
from your sonic.
Not Know.
That's a silly argument.
What do you mean?
Since the probability increases with danger?
Now flying is one of those things.
It's a hobby.
You can't equate deejaying Dj,
dad mouth with flying course.
You can,
there's Molly,
there's percosets or you don't take drugs.
You don't know if one of my Dj gigs,
what I do,
Dj Gigs,
gigs gigging,
man,
I'm totally good and Bro,
right?
So let's,
let's fucking keep talking.
Let's keep the dialogue open.
Dialogue is open.
Um,
it cannot include cars of any time.
God,
nobody wants to hear that and he wants to be,
that's not yellow anymore.
God.
Nobody wants to hear that.
I eating,
I want to do it.
If you,
if you're going to go ahead and blow your nose,
what is wrong with her?
It was me and me with you or whatever.
What was Indio that day?
I had my shark Ne,
you know,
and that's one glass.
I'm crazy.
I mean,
I think as long as you know you're willing to do them,
you're willing to up them with a costumes and scenarios,
role play,
et Cetera,
then it's fine.
Like,
and you got to do,
you've got to wear your glasses.
Um,
you got to say things like,
you know,
I can't,
I can't see when there's no come on my glasses,
things like that.
Then you know that I'm willing to negotiate with you and it's so dumb.
You're the one word that you're the worst husband than ever.
Ever role play.
Yeah.
The lot of sticky calm in those emails
you got.
Stay that to me every single time.
You have to say that to me every time you want to do it,
you do it.
I'll stay out of the sky with the answer.
I have to.
We have to talk more.
I can't just agree to it blindly on the
Oh,
nice.
All right.
You know what's going to happen if I agree with on the show.
Yeah.
Then our listeners are ravenous and they will make meticulous know of everything
I say.
And then I want to petition are the illegal problem for me
or lessons for something.
And I just remembered,
this is something I'm going to ask you.
Um,
and I'm serious.
I want you to do this.
You have any coming those bulls.
I wanted to see if you have coming your balls.
I also am going to ask you if you have not yet to write a review.
Five stars obviously of our show on iTunes.
And there's a reason that I'm asking you to do this.
If you don't know a lot of,
uh,
on the business side of things,
a lot of those people pay attention only to the iTunes charts.
And there's a misleading thing about the iTunes charts in that people can rank
highly on those iTunes charts who don't necessarily have the most people
listening to their show.
And the reason that's important to note is because they then we'll get the
benefit of the presumed bigger show in any number of business conversations.
So like I could be talking to,
I dunno,
I'm just making this up,
but like a,
a book agent about a book and Oh,
the shows this or that and,
and then they go,
okay,
well so and so did a book and they're ranked 15th on the iTunes chart and that
was helped that helped them with their book.
You guys are 41st but then I'll find out even just talking to the person ranked
whatever on the charts that we have a bigger show.
So if you're wondering,
well then why do you know,
why did they get ranked higher?
One of the factors in the algorithm for iTunes podcast charts is reviews.
And you'll notice that a lot of the consistently higher ranked shows have
thousands of read reviews.
And what I also found out is a lot of shows solicit those.
I feel like,
you know,
I know that in when we did our first probably 20 or 40 episodes,
we asked you to do that.
I'm going to ask you to do it again.
Um,
I mean obviously if you've done it,
you've done it,
but I'm going to ask again.
If you've never listened,
if you've never written a review and you have an iTunes account and you don't
mind spending a moment riding a,
a review of our show and you can make them as jeans terrific as you want,
I think it would be beneficial to us.
So that's what I'm asking you to do.
If it's not too much trouble,
um,
I think we could easily,
I know how many people is in the show.
We could easily get thousands of more reviews and that would in turn,
it's an easy way to benefit the show.
So that's my,
my pitch on it and I hope you'll consider doing it.
No.
How many blow jobs where you give the audience for that?
There's no way I can do that.
There's no way.
What do you mean is it's possible?
How is it possible?
Anything's possible.
You can set up a blow job tour.
The Thompson girls suck it for reviews and then no one gets in a line position,
rents out an auditorium and you just give a blowjob after blowjob or how,
how exhausting that would be and how sick I would probably get
is blowing all of our fans who wrote an iTunes review.
Yeah,
it's already,
how sick would you get?
Really sick?
Well,
from what?
I mean all these different does dicks then smells and and,
and just so many different styles and stuff and just all of them.
How many could you do in one day though?
I don't know.
Let's be realistic.
More of the expert in this field.
I mean,
it depends on how fast people are,
you know?
Just because you suggested that Emory
fucking work,
you're women.
Well,
that's what I'm saying.
What's in it for them,
you know?
Well,
a blow job from Thompson [inaudible].
I'm just suggesting that was a horrible idea.
I can't believe you.
It's helped me out like that.
You know what's interesting?
The iTunes ranking,
you're right,
because it also only goes by,
I'm assuming in part by the downloads on iTunes there their thing,
but that's not how it works.
The downloads are also through stitcher streaming through complicated thing,
android,
whatever the fuck people are on,
it's not the only platform in town,
so it's just as soon as they hear,
it's not just down on those.
Now,
if you have like an incredible amount of downloads,
like if you have tens of millions like Joe or like a cereal,
yes,
you'll stay at number one,
two or three because you have the overwhelming downloads.
But I'm telling you,
there are people that have a third yeah.
Of our downloads that are ranked higher than us.
So it was like that's,
it's not fair that the,
uh,
it only matters because it's not an ego thing where I'm like,
I just want to be ranked higher.
It only matters when people start giving consideration to that as if it's a
bigger show.
Right.
That's when it matters.
So anyways,
so weird system.
I'm curious to know how they bagged out.
I've never fucking heard of.
We're in the world of podcasts,
so you kind of know what's out there and I'll look at those and I'll be like,
dude,
who,
well,
there's also this thing where they give benefits to also to new shows.
Yes.
They give him that and that that was done.
That's,
that's by design to give a new show opportunity boosts.
Yeah.
Which I mean,
I understand that for sure.
This is just,
it's just too much fun.
We're having too much fun right now.
This graphic shows how airflow travels and heat is transferred inside an angle
too bad regenerative thermal oxidizer.
Oh my God.
Process gasses are pushed into the inlet main fold of the Rto via a system fan.
These volatile organic compounds.
Hazardous air pollutants.
Fuck is,
we didn't to the first bet of ceramic energy recovery media,
they are progressively heated pool.
Wow.
That was bad.
That was a really boring,
at least she had a kind of a neat voice though.
It wasn't like a dude.
You know who else has a neat voice?
You got to say stuff like that and the blow job negotiation.
I can't talk and give one at the same time.
Take it out for a second.
Um,
what,
let's see if you can solve this mystery girl they didn't.
T carry are investigating the theft of up to 60 sheep on one brand.
One of the farmers is offering a reward for information leading to the return of
the use,
which are worth thousands of euro.
Oh that's right.
Then your own domain and finding that
this is a matter of accent.
Oh,
that guy is,
no,
so I understood the news casters they use when the Udalls but this is other
levels.
60 sheep had been stolen from this poor man.
Oh,
let's see what he has to say about Mike.
He is convinced over 40 sheep have been stolen.
Possible aid.
They'd be a hormonal around latent,
should be right out in academia.
One opened the mountains about night.
Sure.
I wish this guy ran the great British baking show.
Wow.
Why?
What
Mikey is convinced over 40 sheep had been stolen.
Possibly an eight.
That'd be a homeowner possible at night.
Beautiful morning and lightens and students are being priced out in academia.
Entrepreneur by nature.
There's something about it's bright out.
It's Friday night.
Yet the moon shines possible for anyone.
So for liquor,
drink it now.
Okay.
[inaudible] sheep gone count out tonight's bitumen anyway
is teeth are sanity.
He has no teeth pain.
Well he has some,
they are not cool at all.
Let's hear that again.
Oh,
oh look like sheep kind of dark and dingy.
That is dark.
That is rough.
Well that was frosty five sheep miss.
Well it was 45 sheep.
The sheep that's gone.
It's gone.
Talk to most B,
two
B,
doing the vote and lost.
Wait a minute.
Wait,
what do you think's going on there too?
And the Bumblebee mountain five.
Yeah,
in the Bumblebee Mountain.
Bumblebee mountain sheep
missing like in the lamps and there wasn't much shapes.
It's gone.
[inaudible]
uh,
account out to Molly likes the lambs,
the sheep tent,
the tent.
Molly,
they went down the mountain lion.
I went to Bali like mountains on the Molly's on the mountain.
Like
there wasn't much shape.
Just go and talk to most between will lay awake can be done.
The Voltron Lawson,
nothing.
That's English.
That's an man who speaks English his whole life.
Just learning right.
This isn't like a foreign accent syndrome whereby yeah,
English as a second language.
This is this guy's primary.
It's a primary.
It's this,
well like he's next door neighbor says some of his sheep have also been stolen.
It's not all that difficult
of a good jargon.
Go Work Nights,
some moonshine night just for the dog around them.
Put I'm on a trailer or walk them and then probably somebody else to pick him
up.
That guy's pretty,
yeah,
I can understand why that one.
Just for the people that don't,
let's go through his,
well,
like he's next door neighbor says some of his sheep have also been stolen.
Come back,
come back,
come back.
Okay.
He said,
come back,
come back.
He said about 10,
10 year olds,
there's about 10 euros,
10 euros that got stolen.
He lost 10 year olds.
It's not all that difficult.
You only got to do was have a good dog.
You got to do is have a good yard.
Have a good jog,
jog.
He goes on a jog.
Dougan have good Joggin yeah.
Have a good jog.
And how are you good jogging moonshine on a trailer.
Walk and put him on trailer,
watching him walk them poverty.
Somebody has to pick him up.
I'm probably somebody else to pick them up.
Pick them all.
Oh,
the other guy oof.
Shit as fucking crazy man.
Z.
No.
Oh,
he's got my Adidas jacket on this kid.
Yeah,
that's your kid.
It's your kid.
Think he's a good ball worshiper or are you thinking that God,
the daughter,
his son Suns are born to do that.
To worship balls.
Yeah.
This is not a debate.
Good.
Um,
so your big old tits were in uh,
uh,
Braya.
Yeah,
it was great.
Yeah.
Super Fun.
I had Joe Barton.
Nick Open for me.
Yoshi came by,
did a guest spot.
It was awesome.
Where do you got coming up?
Oh,
Shit.
All that out.
We're got to get my life together here,
guys.
Sorry,
I was caught off guard there.
Oh,
I'm on airplane mode.
All right.
Ready?
Uh,
April 28th and 29th sack.
Romantico at the punchline,
the ball,
Sacramento.
May 4th and fifth fart.
Next.
Stand up live.
May 19th and 20th June dork titties.
Gotham.
Calm on your comedy club.
June 1st through third Denver Mom [inaudible] up the comp committee works and
then June 16th and 17th,
man friend disco at the punch line.
Yeah,
that's what I got.
Okay.
That's what's up,
man.
I got to check this shit out this week.
I'm in Fallis,
Texas on Thursday.
There's two shows.
The first one sold out.
There's a late show in Dallas and then Houston,
Houston,
Texas.
The rest of the weekend.
Uh,
or excuse me,
Friday,
Saturday and Sunday.
Um,
as a bunch of shows that have been added,
they're all at Tom Cigarette icon.
But here's what just went on sale.
A Reno,
Nevada,
Tucson,
Arizona,
um,
Pachanga casino that's in Temecula.
And then let's see,
uh,
Richmond,
Virginia,
Virginia Beach,
um,
Greensboro,
North Carolina,
Asheville,
North Carolina.
It goes on sale Friday and Charleston,
South Carolina goes on sale.
It's on sale already this Friday.
Additionally,
Wilmington,
Delaware,
the Grand Opera House is going on sale and Baltimore coming to Baltimore,
July 29th,
uh,
those all go on sale as,
as do Asheville at the orange peel on Friday.
So that's all Tom's [inaudible] dot com slash tour.
Thanks gene.
Very good mommy.
Yeah.
Very good.
Um,
let me see if you like this.
Look at this guy.
Look at this tornado.
Somebody called David Eight one eight three.
Tell him the tornadoes right over his house,
right?
Yes.
Oh my God.
I was waiting for that microwave tower to go.
Never did.
Going to do a plugin anymore,
right?
First of all,
can you see
a guy vomited on tape
background as a tornado is forming?
Isn't that weird?
The hate you so much frame it.
It's weird.
I don't want to fucking hear it again.
Today's video.
It's not a different video.
Listening to this.
I move my headphones on.
I can't hear you,
babe.
Maybe ruined all of that for the audience.
Right then by talking.
No,
because the next video fooled me.
I went to the next clip.
You're lying.
I swear to God.
It's the next clip.
You're not even paying attention.
God,
it's the next clip.
Hey.
Oh wait.
Oh my God.
What is wrong with you?
What do you mean you're the worst person ever?
It's right there.
Worse.
Oh Man.
Are you torturing me today,
Morgan?
Downstairs.
There was just a guy puking his
drains.
Yeah,
I know.
I can gather the other guys like that.
They lost their shingles now.
Totally not checked into his friend vomiting.
I think it's pretty good video.
It's a good clip,
but as usual,
you're not.
You're not here.
You know you're somewhere else.
All right.
This one doesn't have any vomit,
I promise.
How about this?
Do you think it's annoying when people do up speak?
Like speak?
Yeah.
You're lying and you're like,
no,
I just want to wait until I see it before I put my headphones on.
You got to hear it?
Nope.
You go ahead and put the clip up first and then I'll put my headphones on if I'd
be as,
you're one of the great mysteries of the culinary world and since,
how can there be a recipe for re fried beans when there's no such thing as a
fried bean recipe?
This is so much up speak.
You don't know how to speak.
Listen to this intonation as it goes.
Yeah.
Refried beans or one of the great mysteries of the culinary world since,
how can there be a recipe for re fried beans when there's no such thing as a
fried bean recipe?
Usually girls,
they Terry much,
when they go like this and they're like,
oh my God,
like honestly,
seriously,
that's,
here's a some,
oh,
speak to,
no,
I'm going to go ahead.
And so one pound of Pinto beans and cold water over night and like everything
these days,
there's a lot of controversy on whether you should do this or not and I'll let
you do your own research on that.
But I've been to being soaker from way back.
So I did let mine soak in cold water for about tower and is exciting.
Which point they should look something like this.
Is it like this?
It's so weird.
Bizarre.
And we'll add a couple more ingredients,
including some peel garlic as well as a little bit of Eczema or calling up his
otay,
which unless you grow it is not that easy to find fresh,
but it is much easier to find a niche dried form.
And I'm going to go ahead and add a couple of pinches of that in case you're
wondering,
this is sort of an extra strong sort of Minty Oregano.
And if you can't find it,
some dried Oregano will do just fine.
Well,
jazz by everything is,
is up to the speed.
Oh,
that's done.
I do.
That's fine.
What a Gaylord.
Huh?
Such a Gay Lord.
There's no need to do that.
Well why is he doing this?
She's like a real homo.
Oh Hey,
that's not nice.
Oh,
but anyway,
we will bring that to a boil and once it's happened,
we're going to do three things.
So where did they get us here?
We're going to reduce our heat to low,
low.
You're going to let this simmer uncovered for about an hour and a half or so or
until your beans are soft.
Oh,
so this is what mine looks like about 90 minutes later.
We'll go ahead and check these for done.
Done.
This is redundant.
Yeah.
I mean that's probably just,
you think it's a lifetime of that building.
Are you talking like that?
I think he's,
I'm reading copy.
Yeah.
And trying to make comfortable.
Yeah,
right.
Should I make an affliction?
Yeah.
He's trying to make it interesting cause he's reading it by a piece by piece.
So he's trying to be exciting.
So he said don't be afraid.
Don't give that Lard.
And he'll starts to Brown up who bound.
I don't be afraid yet.
What do you prefer?
Somebody with ups speak,
so don't be afraid.
Let it cook amounts of barfing and you're going to play pro or vocal.
Megan and I have been together for nearly three years.
She's a beautiful girl who I am very much in love with and I have a lot in
common with
up speak all day.
What about you,
and I thought this was getting pretty close right here.
Definitely up speaking vocal fry,
vocal fry.
You guys can hear it if you're new to the show.
It's when it's,
people don't realize it's actually deliberate.
You're,
yeah,
you're trying to sound like your
board.
Think that that's the way somebody speaks.
It's not,
it's always a force thing,
but it can be so much a pattern for you that you don't even think but to go like
that.
It's actually actually I think like,
and again we'll do it to sound like I'm bored or whatever.
And again,
you usually hear it more with women.
Yeah,
it's a thing.
We happen to have two examples of men doing it.
It's just bananas.
Megan and I have been together for nearly three years.
She's a beautiful girl who I am very much in love with and I have a lot in
common with.
I can't I to get home and jump in the pool
and the pool.
I will say I'm proud that he didn't say me and Megan because me and something
has become the new norm with grammar and it's making me bananas.
Is it really?
Oh,
I can't stand it.
You never say me and so and so.
Me and Tom,
I know Tom and I are Tom and me depending on the rest of the sentence.
Yeah,
we have makes me crazy.
That doesn't bother you.
I know and me and Tom,
I don't like it.
Me and Megan,
you fucked hard.
Some emails came in.
You've probably been told this already,
but you're smelly.
A C and your car is most likely due to a dirty cabin filter.
The air filter inside your,
your rides.
If you don't feel like getting them replaced,
just rub your finger along your crack and smell it and take a whiff.
Then the AC won't seem so bad.
Take it to any oil change place.
They can glass your filters and then have dad boners when they charge you about
$200 to replace it.
Make sure you stay hydrated.
While you wait.
Yeah.
Right.
Jeans and sampling a double pipe classic.
It is worth to get done though.
So your car's won't smell like the gays.
Uh,
feel better Steve and fart nicks in parentheses.
Don't assume my gender.
Um,
thank you Steve for that.
Uh,
and this is amazing.
Here we have uh,
a Zim sent in an email.
It says,
Hey Mommy buns and Tina,
I'm here to give you some insight to the life of a frequent wash cloth user.
Oh my God.
Please.
Not only do I use a washcloth in the shower,
I happened to use three yes,
three washcloths,
one for my face,
one for my body and one very special washcloth for getting deep down into Brown
town.
Hmm.
I know it sounds like a lot of laundry.
It's well worth it and I encourage my favorite mommy's to give it a try.
The be whole wash cloth is usually used for my extra nasty king ass ripper
browns that happened frequently.
I don't have the luxury of a washlet after making spicy browns and screaming big
words on the toilet.
This is the best solution I've come up with so far.
Any other solution are welcomed and embraced.
Keeping it high and tight.
Never low and loose.
Much loved in my mommy's p s use extra bleach and the wash.
Yeah.
Nash.
Wow.
That's from Nash.
So he's just saying that he's extra nasty.
He's saying he's very nasty.
He farts
and he um,
you know,
he has a,
a dirty,
so he'd rather use a wash cloth then use his hand.
Yeah.
We are,
um,
obviously hand to ask washers in this house and I don't care.
For those who don't know,
we're,
you know,
we're very much
endorsers of the handout as well because then you can just wash your hand with
the soap.
That's what the soap is.
Four.
So it was for doing that.
Yeah.
You know,
the soap kills that bacteria.
You think you're,
you're going to get on your hands anyways.
I also want to add to the blow job negotiation that every time right before you
start,
you have to say,
you have to say it.
Okay.
You mean I don't go?
He got any covering those bowls.
You can try that.
Those bulls.
You got any common those balls?
I like that one.
Of course I do better.
Of course.
Of course I do.
Idiot,
what a stupid question.
It was always combing those bones.
You dumb fuck you rhetorical.
Fuck.
So you got an eight.
And he's like,
mmm,
tastes good,
too.
Really Nasty.
Uh,
when do you,
uh,
when your toilet paper,
do you fold or do you crunch up in a ball fold?
Yeah.
Well,
I think crunching up in a ball is for savages.
I mean,
how do I go over I you do the mittens,
the shit 100%.
I bet my father bunches up.
But then let's do it right now.
I've got this role.
See this is right.
So you go like this,
right?
Here we go.
And then what?
He goes like this.
Absolutely.
But that doesn't even,
he's so nasty.
I bet you he does.
That doesn't cover enough surface area.
Just a ball and none of that.
There's a lot of gaps.
So your knuckles can get shitty.
Now that's silly.
Here's what I do.
I'll show you right here.
Ready,
Huh?
Yeah,
I do like,
I'll be all like,
hold on.
You know like this dude,
I do like that.
I'm fucking put like a shit and men and then that's how I roll.
Let me see what you do.
Here's what I do.
This is the perfect amount.
This is exactly like how much I would use on a brown wipe.
Hello?
I'm trying to get this phone call ready.
I'm gonna try to call him and ask him.
Wait,
but,
but real talk.
Listen.
Okay.
This is enough for my brown.
I want to see how much you use.
Okay.
This is what I know for a yellow,
I would use like a quick,
don't look,
don't let you let you do yours.
I do mine and then let's do
this would be a good for a wipe
look how much less use.
Oh that's it.
I use like double what you use.
Do you use so much?
Because I don't want this shit to touch my hand.
I want to make sure that there's enough of a barrier.
Beep you use like two.
There's only two tissue layers between your hand and your butthole was this
terrible babe.
You got to use more.
We can afford it.
Do it.
I do on occasion.
It just depends on the left,
but on a normal way.
It's been for godly man.
Fucking
why do either of my parents have phones?
Your mother never answers.
It's so annoying.
So annoying.
And like Ellis will be doing something super cute and we'll try to facetime or,
and she'll never fuck it.
Answer.
Yeah.
So now let me ask you this.
When you make yellow,
do you have to wipe your penis ever?
No.
No guys,
don't what?
You don't wet the dribble.
Isn't there a dribble?
I mean,
maybe when you were at 80 or something,
but no,
I don't do it.
He's so little.
This is not even enough for me.
Let me see.
Let me hold it is enough for a yellow light.
No,
that's enough.
I'm like,
I might go a little thicker.
Yeah,
you're fine.
Really.
Wait a minute,
but don't you dig when you wipe,
you got to get in there.
I mean,
I'm saying on it
regular,
just like I'm wiping,
this is fine,
but for me every way was a dig wipe.
If I'm wiping brown.
True.
You're not wiping thoroughly.
Yeah.
And actually,
and after the a washlet one,
like a home one.
Oh,
it's definitely a,
well,
it's different.
Yeah.
The bid day is like,
you know,
you barely have to wipe after the big day now isn't it gross to be on the road
and to shit without a bad day?
Yeah.
Why don't you feel horrible?
What I do,
I use a lot of sinks,
you know?
Really?
Yeah.
What do you do?
Spread my ass in the sink and let the water run through.
Do you shit the shower.
You should
just kosher at the shower.
No,
I don't do shit to shower,
you know,
chat or
hey,
it's your son.
Oh my gosh.
You just go in the house of course.
And no one answers the phone.
It goes,
I sold one to one.
Okay.
You don't have to say the whole number.
Um,
what are you doing?
No,
talking on the phone with you.
So you just didn't answer.
Where's dad?
She went to the gym.
She should be home really soon.
Okay.
Let me ask you this.
When you make,
when you wipe for a Gaca Yeah.
Do you fold the paper over or do you just bunch it up like put it in a ball
is in most disgusting conversation.
Again,
I tell you what went to talk about Ellis.
No,
no,
but which do you do?
We will.
We will hold the paper.
You fold it.
Of course.
Do you think dad does not?
Do you know that for a fact?
No,
I never got to watch and green [inaudible]
excuse me.
Let me check your [inaudible].
I can possible imagine him taking now that you ask it person come in very,
it's more questions I can possible imagine your five fold in impacts.
What about you?
Do you fold it?
I do fold it,
but I told Christina cause we were having as I go,
I bet $1,000 that my dad bunches it up into a ball.
I cannot get in the bed.
Can you get into bed?
The Bet?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
What do you think?
I don't think it pulled us.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's right here.
Right now.
I like to spread.
What do his do you,
do you ever,
okay.
How about this?
Do you ever,
let's say you're traveling and you had a,
uh,
you know,
whatever,
you didn't bring enough underwear.
Do you ever fold your underwear inside out and where this,
the outside as your underwear,
what's happening is I,
it's my,
I know.
No,
I'm saying,
I'm saying in the scenario that you don't have enough,
would you just fold your underwear inside out and where that,
no,
I watch it at night.
I'm 80.
Hopefully it would be dying.
But would you ever do what I'm proposing?
I don't think a way that it can dry
your percentage intuition,
that doesn't happen to me,
but yes,
I will follow this.
Ida.
Okay.
And like,
even if they're,
let's say,
wait,
wait.
I have to be really stupid.
If I am going on a trip,
the first thing I'm counting how many days I'm going on,
the first thing I put is counting under work.
Extra.
How in the world I'm gonna end with no underwear.
Yeah,
somebody's stolen.
That's what happened.
Okay.
Yes.
Yeah.
And how about this one?
Let's say you have Gaca.
I know.
Oh,
hold on.
Hold on.
This is the last one.
Is it?
Okay.
Is it okay if,
if you,
if you get caca on the inside of your underwear,
is it okay to fold it over and just where the outside,
absolutely.
No,
no.
I'm folded inside out.
So we're going to your pants and you will know what is it?
This is the most disgusting conversation.
Number one is impossible to happen to me.
Maybe for you.
I had the feeling that we just happened to you to buy 103.
That's not exciting.
You're one with Brian,
you to 100 words for the present day.
You turned inside out the next day you put in your path,
and then when you don't know what to do to you,
put it back and use it.
The Cacao Nibs.
But I am,
oh my God.
And you afford to buy any on your work?
Uh,
I'm going to try to,
I'm going to get some more.
Yeah,
I'm going to get some more being a dummy.
She's right here.
Christina.
I'm here.
Yeah.
What about it?
I mean,
this is my life.
Yeah,
she's hearing it here.
It,
it's just part of life.
So do you,
do you watch top dogs boxers by any chance?
Oh yeah.
Do you ever Wash Dad's underwear?
What do I give it?
It's the only person who it at me.
Okay.
And what do you want to know?
Any,
I have literacy.
Caucus is underwear.
I never see anything.
I even,
this is disgusting,
but anything,
it's melon because I'm not sure if he's there to clean.
Oh,
you're so brave.
And then do you ever see yellow though?
No.
No yellow either.
If I ever see yellow,
if I happened once or twice,
I get it with two fingers and put it sideways.
I can spray it before that.
Well,
no.
And then you never see Brown streaks in the underwear.
You know,
it used to be in the old times,
she did have that.
Oh,
I only have to repay it in a long time.
Charles,
I gotta I gotta grab this call.
I'll call you back.
I love you.
Okay.
Love you.
Bye.
Hello?
Hello.
Hey Tom.
Hey Dad.
Hey,
it's your son.
It's your son.
Big Dog.
Hey,
what's up man?
I didn't recognize the number.
I know I'm calling you from back.
How was it?
Just come back from the gym dad workouts or up to an hour now?
Great.
I'm very happy for you.
That's great.
I have,
um,
I got,
I got it.
I got a serious question.
I gotta ask you.
Okay.
Hold on.
Let me do a fart.
Okay.
Did the part time.
So,
um,
when you take a dump,
do you fold the paper over or you just bunch it up and wipe with it?
He bunches.
Oh,
I'm a bunch of,
you're a bunch or
yeah.
Oh yeah.
I knew it.
You know that I knew it.
We had a bet going and I knew it.
Folders or OCD.
People need break.
Yeah.
You know,
uh,
it's not good people that didn't actually,
you know.
Well that's for all my dirty clothes in the laundry hamper and miss.
I get it in the morning.
Okay.
You know it's,
I know it's me that my problem with bunching is it like if I'm looking at paper,
if I bunch,
um,
if you get some and you wipe with a bunch and you happen to look at it,
you could release some of that paper and have it all spread out.
It gets like real messy,
right?
No,
never gets messy.
You have to know how to do it,
get yourself,
makes you a plenty of paper.
And then you know,
I always go in for the wet ones,
the kind of,
and then I do a couple of weapons and make sure I got it all in and go back to
the dry ones and ever.
My,
the very last one,
I kind of punch it in the bottle hole a little bit,
make sure there's not something kind of oozed out.
Wait,
see you and you puncture yourself a little bit with it.
Like you actually push it in
just a little bit.
It's just kind of a hard place.
Make sure I don't go all the way in,
but just around in the head,
you know what I mean?
Sure.
Doesn't,
it doesn't kind of leak out and,
uh,
you know,
end up in your underwear.
And so I,
you know,
I got this down pat and uh,
and then I did one of my,
well,
my one final one.
There's nothing on it.
I know.
I'm good to go.
Wow.
That's pretty good.
I mean,
we have a couple other scenarios we wanted to ask you about underwear.
Do you feel like it's okay to wear underwear inside out?
Yeah,
sure.
I mean,
you know,
I'm trying to become more planet sensitive,
and um,
a lot of things that,
you know,
I understand that we all have to take care of the planet and waste.
You know what,
I grabbed the California,
you get those real efficient toilets where one button for a piss and to another
button for a dump.
Okay.
Yeah,
we don't have those here in Florida.
Okay.
Right.
Um,
we're,
we're not weight,
not that far advanced.
So,
you know,
I figure I can,
uh,
if I just turn him honorary inside out,
they can't do that with boxers that you can deal with grief.
Gotcha.
Now do you feel like,
um,
this is a scenario,
let's say somebody has an accident in their underwear.
How about flipping them inside out?
If you have no other underwear,
is that acceptable or no?
No.
At that?
No,
no,
no.
You just got throw the hat and that happened to me in Orlando.
You remember?
Yeah.
Yep.
Accident.
You just got to clean your butt up real good.
And you just got to throw the underwear away.
Hmm.
No scenario,
Huh?
Yup.
No scenario now cause it ends up in your draft.
Oh yeah.
I never thought of that part one.
If your trousers get muddy.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's what I'm saying.
But no,
the housers we'll get money out.
I think you just,
when you have that,
that one episode where you,
your,
your underwear,
it got messy.
You just have to make sure you're,
you're,
you're kind of clean there and then hope for the best.
Okay.
No,
you can get to put their underwear.
Yeah.
Wow.
Interesting.
Did you tell him,
I'll tell you what I do now.
Yes.
This is,
I do not carry an extra set of underwear in my carry on luggage.
Wow.
Josh,
then k
you told me the other day that you farted and then you knew exactly what was
coming.
Yeah.
You remember that?
You called me Joe.
Oh yeah,
Mike,
I got,
you know,
I can tell by the smell of the Farc what number the dumps going to be.
And you said it was like a four or five.
Yeah,
I can tell.
And they had like the other day I have it.
Yes.
They had a three,
three part.
I noticed I have a three coming.
Okay.
And sure enough I did about 45 minutes later,
edit three.
That's really some.
Um,
that's cool man.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
as you get older you develop certain skills for certain things and it's
definitely a scary cat.
Yeah.
MMM.
Okay.
Well look,
I uh,
can I give you a call back here in a few minutes?
Do you mind?
I'll give you a call.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'll call you back in a few,
like,
all right,
I love you.
Bye Bye.
Bye.
Well we got a definitely a bunch or full report.
Two,
we got your mom's perspective and your dad's that was bonus for sure.
That was a bonus material and she was really upset at the question.
So mission accomplished.
More fun.
Um,
remember the uh,
the,
the Nelson Mandela hockey player?
Yeah.
Somebody said,
um,
let me see.
I don't,
I haven't read it yet,
but this is the email I was listening to your podcasts toward the end.
I hear a very familiar clip.
The hockey player,
Jonathan.
Uh,
I think it's Bernay talking about influential Mr Mandela,
how influential Mr Mandela was to him playing hockey.
I live in Toronto,
huge maple leafs fan.
So this club hits home for me.
He got absolutely roasted on Toronto radio for that.
This guy was supposed to be the savior for the leaves.
He was a young up and coming goalie that was traded for from your La Kings.
He had a pretty good first year and a half.
Then it's video happened.
He was so bad after that.
Like so,
so fucking bad.
He is no longer playing for trial.
He's back in California playing for Anaheim,
playing really good.
Again.
I think this actually fucked with his head when he was here.
Wow.
Love the show.
Mommy's can't wait for both of you to come to do another show in Toronto a lot.
I live podcasts.
Maybe Canadia would really like that.
Love you.
Mommy's Nathan.
I do love Toronto.
Toronto's that Shit.
It is wonderful.
Toronto.
Yeah.
I love,
I like Canada and through the good times.
Not La,
but it's Canada.
You know what I mean?
Right.
That's a good way of breaking it down to,
it's not la,
but it is.
Canada is Canada.
I like Canada.
Is,
uh,
is that,
well,
you were saying,
but it's something else,
right?
That is my logic.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's crazy.
I can see that happening.
I mean,
on the great British baking show,
you have a bad bake and the judges lean into you and then it gets in your head.
It's hard to bounce back from that much heat,
you know?
Yeah,
of course.
It must have been a very embarrassing incident.
You know,
I actually do.
Did I tell you this is how much I actually empathize with that,
even though I,
you know,
I made fun of him or whatever.
Yeah.
When that clip started before the show,
when I was making sure my clips were lined up and he said the first line of
like,
he was a great player,
I turned it off because of my own embarrassment.
Yes.
Yeah.
I get that way from fortified,
man.
Well,
you know it,
it happens.
Do we?
Do I know everything?
No.
Do you know
everything in the world?
No.
And then on those moments is red carpet moment.
Just a microphone in your face and a camera.
And he's not,
he's not a,
he's not an actor.
He's not a comedian.
He's a hockey player.
So I always feel like that too,
to make athletes talk on the spot.
Yeah.
And in those,
you know,
it's a high pressure situation.
I get it.
By the way.
I thought like the cause of my pants were so funny.
Let's like tropical down.
Sorry.
We got to be looking at another way of dealing with it in have a generic,
he's in the field for a trick nine as the Spin Echo.
Let's go back to first principles for a moment.
Oh my God.
Remember that that oscillating transfers may get getting field has the effect of
causing that nuclear mechanization to move from it's equilibrium position
reporting along with the magnetic field to being preseason at some particular
angle five and angle four maximum second is to have that mega [inaudible] lying
in the transverse plane.
You know what I think about when I watched it like this,
he likes to fuck this guy fucks day and night.
Also,
we need,
there's a need for this type of human being on earth.
Yeah,
and thank God that it just happened.
Cause I look at it like please fill me with bullets right now.
But there are people that are like,
this is what,
this is what I live for.
This puts a lead in his pencil.
Oh yeah,
this guy wakes up and I got,
cause I got a bullet for you right now.
It's at the tip of my day.
This oscillating thing.
I'm s I'm just geeked on this bro.
Yeah.
Thank God for smart people basically is what you're saying.
That is what I'm saying.
Um,
look,
before we go,
I feel like I'm smart.
We do owe it to at least the people involved to finish that audio.
No,
it is like sad music.
It is like a,
like a procedural.
You're right.
Yeah.
Telephone order
in the court of law.
It's the moment where,
um,
the person that you didn't think was a suspect was putting together the,
uh,
putting together the evidence and they're like,
then you came back.
No.
Yeah.
You saw that she was still in the house
right
next
to intense.
It's
kind of a bummer.
It puts a bummer mood on,
which should be fun thing.
Right?
A light playful romp is now a murder.
I don't know though,
because it was exchange.
It's very aggressive.
This sexcapade really,
I mean you here,
it sounds fun.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Sounds light and consensual a man.
That was kind of
fun.
You're right.
That was fun.
I don't know what I was thinking.
Yeah.
I wish our nanny could hear this.
Sham.
This will be it on this one.
I have to tell you,
this is very,
you're fainting.
This is why I quit.
No,
don't quit.
Do much about it now.
Uh,
this would devastate her.
Yeah.
Thank God for a soundproof studio.
Huh?
Oh Man.
A lot of these songs,
God,
I don't know which one you want to hear.
There's so much.
How about not aggressive coming and not shitting?
Cause we've done enough common shit today.
Okay.
Hmm.
I can't so I shouldn't play.
We both got aids.
Um,
there's triple pipe montage.
I think that sounds pretty fun,
but oh no,
that's,
that's shit.
Double Pipe.
Yeah.
So don't do that.
Got Any common those don't do that.
I'm having a hard time now finding a close or this one's called,
it's a piece of asphalt dude and a Canadian Denim boner is another one.
Okay.
Let's try that
with the ever increasing demand for greater speed.
Generic crap.
Sorry.
Thanks for listening.
You guys funny.
We'll see you next time.
Thanks Jean.
Mom's house,
podcast.com.
Bye Bye.
Oh,
why isn't the government talking about cars?
We welcome guests too.